you seconde c'est squeeze aujourd'hui on
se trouve non pas sur un jeu mais on va
jouer à un jeu wii j'ai mis dix minutes
à trouver cette phrase
d'habitude c'est souvent les abonnés qui
posent leurs questions ou youtube heures
comme moi par exemple d'emblée
queenstown taille mais aujourd'hui je me
suis dit et si c'est moi qui posais des
questions à mes abonnés 1
ça vous plaît - oui première question
fait un même avec cette photo non
habitable c'est quoi cette pêcheurs
stehlé d'entrée de jeu si tu vas faire
même nom mais s'il vous plaît
moi je les prends bien vos questions et
je suis au top tout un des ford attend
ça dit quoi là pas mal ça c'est un
photomontage très vilain 1 2 puis 2 puis
causé des larmes ça un miroir miroir est
ce que je suis le plus beau je pense que
miroir ne serait déjà plus la somalie
ouais même pas me répondre je cherche le
problème bas m'ont dit que je suis
normal assaf creux à la violence petit
c'est toi qui as kfc moi je donne direct
je donne monsieur chez williams avait
des tribunaux tant qu'être bon son et à
cesser leur deuxième question si je
devais vous séduire vous en tant
qu'abonné que vous soyez un homme ou une
femme comment devrais je m'y prendre tu
ne t'y prends pas
dieu te monde c'est squeeze d'accord ok
donc si jamais un jour je vais de reggae
quelqu'un je lui dis bien tout le monde
sait squeeze c'est bon ça ensemble
maintenant c'est impossible avoir une
moustache bien pimpante et voilà comme
ça au fond naturel et sens ton haleine
je dois sens mon haleine athée je sais
me fait tout s'est tu te concentres
allen arrêté nicolas loiseau tu m'offres
une ps4 et là je t'adore j'arrive mon
amour nicolas loiseau ni combinaison non
tu m'avais promis de ne pas le faire ça
de façon ces papous ils sont meilleurs
que les tiers des 12 toi ça suffit tu
devrais changer de visage web app ps
catella bien mon visage hockey quand tu
fais la vaisselle et que tu touches un
bolide nourriture regardez cette
bouchons pour la coller sur un visage de
stars qu'elle passe parfaitement bien
encore exemple scarlett johansson up
michael tu te fous à oilpé tu donnes
moscow avec la tête du pervers à ton mec
juste
aucune personne au monde qui
accepteraient quelqu'un france troisième
question un enfant vous double dans la
queue de la boulangerie et vous regard
avec cette tête que faites-vous jeu
craquement dans le mec vient de doubler
quand même un pour acheter une baguette
un doctorat ta baguette 10 secondes de
retard je m'enfuis pas tu sais que cette
réaction
c'est un enfant plus tard la claque non
non non non ce que le pape a fait 200 kg
ha dont 120 kg muscles donc tu te calmes
j'ai peur j'ai peur
non non je trouve toujours toujours pas
gros tu peux avoir peur je le frappe
avec une baguette
même s'il a une baguette aussi et qui
ripostent sa part en duel de baguettes
je tente un dépassement avec musique
épique pour une baguette de pain
d'accord je pense que je réagis comme ça
tu fais un match de foot avec lui dans
la boulangerie je le traite de mal
éduqués et si il continue de regarder
avec cette tête
qu'est ce que tu fais bon c'est l'heure
de la troisième question quel est le
premier réflexe que vous avez au réveil
regardez mon téléphone dans life
regardez mon téléphone nolife faire un
câlin à mon amoureux au comme celui de
niaux a été de faire semblant
bon je vois les différentes
personnalités quoi lyonnais qu'il faut
je suis un petit câlin à mon doudou or
mon jeu je me fait renifler la figure
par mon gentil chat aussi mignon arrêté
arrêté boire deux litres de café tabac
près pendant la journée c'est comme ça
quoi sa gamme question quel est votre
meilleur dessin voilà parce que j'ai eu
plein de gens se moquaient de ma manière
de décider des pokémon et j'étais
scandalisé 1 ou pas du tout mais ça
c'est normal mais où j'étais scandalisé
quand même pas de pokémon en tout cas
voilà voilà vous voyez ça se voit ou
encore ça suffit
watteau tour mais oui mais la
ressemblance est là regardez les deux
doigts comme ça non sans déconner ton
dessin me rappelle qu'il faut absolument
que je change de coupe de cheveux
voilà parce que je m'aperçois que c'est
exactement la même que sur la photo
effectivement et que c'est horrible
c'est moche pitt artistique cette coupe
un couteau je crois le voilà c'est vrai
qu'il est bien fait mais pourquoi tu
dessines et un couteau tu es un
dangereux psychopathe qui tuent des gens
la nuit dans une baignoire dans un genre
ajouteront un point regarde points ah
ouais au ici si la ressemblance
regardez les lèvres oui oui oui un peu
quand même me vanter à mes dessins sont
meilleurs que ça voilà c'est après un
fan avis que je dis cette phrase comme
c'est mignon regarder il est tout mignon
il veut des croquettes
il veut un câlin peut-être juste parce
qu'il veut peut-être qu'il veut rien ou
simplement les sur le en paix en fait je
pouvait effacer squeeze même brad pitt
avec une flèche que vous croyez la même
chose quoi mais c'est pratique c'est
pratique en fait tu peux offrir ce
dessin qui tu veux juste une change le
nom qui au bout de la flèche et hop
avions pas la fête des mères maman
flèche et voilà un dessin dans un
dessein wola l'a vraiment j'aurais
jamais dû poser de questions olala aux
non stop stop droit mais regardez-moi ça
comment ils font mais comment juger
pulsions sa noce
je ne sais pas mais je pourrais passer
dix heures par jour a décidé que je
faisais seront progrès quoi je suis sûr
que parmi vous il y en a qui sont dans
le même cas que moi
arrêtons dessinée chantons plutôt
radioactive radio rwanda chantons pas
finalement à j'ai trouvé un dessin
vraiment bien fait il très réaliste on
dirait presque que tu a dessiné sur une
photo quand même c'est l'heure de la
sixième question la plus grosse honte de
votre vie
rien n'arrête eu aucune arrête de dire
que je regarde des vidéos
quand je regarde des vidéos
non non attends mais non je rigole non
non en mille triche
le père dans un magasin et pas retrouver
ma mère ne sait pas la honte c'est la
panique
être sur la poste d'accueil de l'ipad
est appuyé sur le bouton pour quitter
une application est quoi l'ipad s'est
moqué de toi tu avais honte c'est ça
qu'est ce que c'est que ce dessin j'ai
pas acceptent des simples plus marrant
lui dire un arbre caprivi comme ça sur
lequel la mode a greffé une sorte de
pelouse mais il a tout de même une
petite moustache pour avoir un certain
style pleurer en regardant kung fu panda
ce n'est pas une blague
comment as tu pu pleurer devant kung fu
panda c'est comme si tu pleurais je sais
pas devant doha voilà parce que tel fois
une question est quel temps gueule de me
faire battre une seule fois au judo par
une fille mais après j'ai tout gagné
en même temps si la figure ressembler à
ça c'est légitime de perles
je suis ton frère trois traversées quand
la voiture de mon pote accélère ou
sortir de la boulangerie bousculer une
dame est ce que la dame en se retournant
à léry cette tête dans la classe il y
avait une punaise sur mon cahier je les
ai vus j'ai eu tellement peur que
que je suis tombé j'ai fait que j'ai eu
en lisant ce tweet je me suis dit la
chute va être terrible en une fois que
tu as vu ça tu restes un peu comme ça
devant ton écran
ah ouais d'accord bon 7e question fait
un photomontage avec ça s'est tirée
d'une vidéo je ne sais toujours pas
comment je vais faire cette tête
on va voir ce que vous allez en faire au
premier montage qui n'est pas des
moindres
merci c'est tout pour moi c'était page
terrasson bomb voilà squeeze déjà la
calvitie
oh merde attendez attendez attendez il
ya quand même un avantage là il me
semble que ça s'appelait à quelqu'un un
quelqu'un qui était là au début de la
vidéo
moi j'ai la presse que je suis en train
de manger des sandwichs très bien fait
bravo je vous présente ce quiz est non
mais là tu l'as fait ce que vous êtes au
bois de boulogne mais ça va pas la
colline a des yeux 3 bientôt au cinéma
romane j'aime bien en fait dans ce
montage c'est que florent audrey s'est
beaucoup impliqué on peut voir des mains
parfaitement détour est vraiment une
incrustation d'une poitrine vraiment
bien fait ça n'a aucun sens quelle est
la chose dont vous êtes le plus fier
avec preuve de toi oh comme c'est mignon
au nom cette fois on se bat pas les
steaks au mercy avec mauvaise foi
extrêmement rare que tu me fall o weh
high five et voilà les gens c'est déjà
la fin de cette vidéo c'était assez
court je sais malheureusement ça m'a
pris beaucoup de temps de faire cette
vidéo pour j'espère quand même que ça
vous aura plu
et si c'est le cas comme d'habitude
n'hésitez pas à aimer la vidéo
surprenante
je pensais que j'allais dire autre chose
par exemple manger du cassoulet merci à
tous ceux qui ont joué le jeu et qui ont
répondu aux questions je me suis
vraiment un super moment avec vos
chaînes bien de quoi faire des vidéos
comme ça où on est plus proche vous
intervenez directement dans la vidéo
vous m'avez bien fait marrer on se
retrouve très vite dans une nouvelle
vidéo comme d'habitude ça où tout le
monde ici
[Musique]